good evening thank you very much for
coming out is the sound turned up on
this okay
just my imagination this evening Barnes
and Noble is extremely honored to host
Erna Paris the author of long shadows
truth lies in history miss Paris will
take you on a journey across four
continents to explore how nations
reinvent themselves and how history how
the historical and shape their
historical memory in the aftermath of
calamity
please welcome Erna Paris thank you
thank you very much this is the end of a
three-week to continent tour to
publicize the publication of long
shadows and I'm particularly happy to be
here because there are people in this
audience who actually form a part of my
book as you will see the questions I
asked myself when I began to think about
writing long shadows had to do with the
way the narrative of history is shaped
especially after times of crisis in a
nation's history who for example decides
what actually happened yesterday who
decides what will get written into the
history books and what will get left out
why do they make the choices they make
why is it that many countries cannot lay
the past to rest and most important
perhaps what are the consequences of the
way the past is remembered especially
for those people and they are often
cultural or religious minorities or the
victims of war who may be deliberately
left out of the national story
some of these questions have been on my
mind for many years in the early 1960s
as a young student living in France I
happen to visit a former Nazi death camp
in the forests of the Vosges mountains
near Strasbourg the visit was deeply
shocking not least because my friends
and I had more or less stumbled upon
that unmarked place during a carefree
weekend outing I began to wonder about
the way war was remembered and to ask
questions what emerged was that the
people who had been murdered at that
camp most of whom were Jews seemed to
have been left out of the picture of the
Second World War
altogether less than two decades after
the fact the public memory of the French
focused on the heroics of the resistance
under General Charles de Gaulle no one
talked to me about the collaborationist
government of Vichy France unlike now
when the subject is of obsessive
interest to the French I actually began
to research long shadows by accident in
early 1996 I was invited to Japan for
other reasons and since I was going to
be there I decided to visit Hiroshima
and Nagasaki I was curious about how the
survivors of the nuclear bombings
remembered this devastating event and
also about the way the Japanese in
general regarded this seminal moment in
their history of course I had no idea
that I was beginning a massive
three-year journey across four
continents in search of the way the past
is remembered but it wasn't long before
I came to realize that what I was
learning in the bombed cities of
southern Japan meshed effortlessly with
my long-standing interest in the subject
of historical memory
my first stop in both Hiroshima and
Nagasaki was to visit the museums that
have been erected in memory of the
nuclear bombings and to talk to the
museum directors but what I noticed
almost immediately was that there seemed
to be no context to the displays the
stories of the attacks and their
terrible effects on the people of both
these cities was well documented as one
would expect but there was nothing to
recall the war itself
least of all acts committed by the
Japanese military in China and elsewhere
this was symptomatic of the way history
has been taught in Japan with next to
complete silence about the wartime past
indeed just recently the Ministry of
Education
once again issued textbooks that ignored
Japan's important role in that conflict
I interviewed Hitachi motojima the
former mayor of Nagasaki who was shot at
by right-wing extreme right-wingers in
1985 after he declared after he dared to
suggest that Emperor Hirohito the
titular and real head of the country
during the war held ultimate
responsibility Mojo Shima recovered but
he was quietly and sometimes not so
quietly called quote unjam ease for
having dared to voice and apparently
treasonous opinion some of the nuclear
survivors I met did agonize over the
fact that the complete history of the
Second World War is still not taught to
school children in Japan some had
adopted a fatalistic approach to both
past and present but from my point of
view as a writer studying the way
historical memory evolves Japan had not
begun to face the complexity of its
second world war past and I'd like to
read you a few paragraphs from long
shadows
my guide Kiko and I drive to another
part of the city to the home of dr. Co
so module in the way of the culture his
medical office is in his house complete
with an ante room where he can practice
surgery he doesn't want to talk about
what happened to him on August 6 1945
except to say that he was made sterile
and never fathered a child with his wife
instead he hands me a stapled together
manuscript full of cross-outs
and translated by himself into something
approximating English the title is too
much worried recently dr. Matsu Oh
worries about many things why did the
United States not warn will not warn
Japan about the possible nuclear
bombings of human beings he asks me
apparently expecting an answer as we sit
together on a coach in his living room
he has met lots of Americans and he
thinks they feel guilty about this I
know Japan did horrible things to others
but then there were the terrible fire
bomb attacks on Tokyo wasn't that
reprisal enough or did the a-bomb
represent some sort of balance of
victims
maybe this bomb was necessary he says
maybe it couldn't be helped I am
startled to hear it again this
fatalistic idea it can't be helped and
the surprising but not uncommon belief
that the bomb might have been quote
necessary to bring quote balance into
the conflict he agonizes over questions
of ethics two years have passed since
the Japanese government was pressured
into acknowledging the fact of Korean
quote comfort women who were forced to
sexually service Japanese soldiers at
the front he wants the survivors to
receive an official apology and payment
from government coffers to indicate real
remorse on behalf of the Japanese people
he wants to build schools and countries
Japan invaded in which truthful history
will be taught
he wishes Japan were a quote real
democracy where people were free to
think independently and voice their
opinions we only want to forget he
mourns he shows his tortured writings to
his friends in the Hiroshima Lions Club
but they never say anything except oh
what a fine writer you are such
excellent style as for the younger
members of his family they dismiss him
as a silly old man with boring memories
of bygone times how important is it to
express opinions that conform with other
people's I ask him he looks perplexed
and even the fluently bilingual
interpreter must look up the word
conform I explain to conform means to
act and perhaps think in the same way as
others ah says Keiko after a moment and
writes down the Japanese word wah for my
edification hua means harmony wah Toto
boo means the harmonious whole she nods
vigorously as she explains it means let
us discuss things but aim for the
harmonious whole we will endure
discussion if we must then we will
return to war we will endure discussion
here it seems to me is a key to the
reluctance to debate let alone resolve
the erasure of wartime atrocities from
public memory and an explanation for the
evasive response of dr. Matsu hos
friends in the lions club a glimpse into
ancient cultural attitudes that continue
to survive beyond the veil of
westernization as the culture of
Buddhism and Shintoism made it possible
for army propagandists to suggest that
spirit can conquer physical death and
war so the religious cultural ideal of
WA makes open dissent virtually
impossible in many quarters beyond the
government censorship of history texts
lies the culture itself
when I began to think about writing a
broader book on the way collective
memory is shaped after calamitous events
such as Hiroshima and Nagasaki I quickly
realized I could effectively pick and
choose from dozens of situations around
the world I could have explored the
troubles in Northern Ireland or
unassimilated Nazi memory in Austria or
the unfinished lurch from communism to
capitalism in China or the rocky
transition to something new in the
former Soviet Union in fact once I began
thinking about it the list was endless
since it now seems evident to me that
every country mythologize --is its past
to a greater or lesser degree this book
also looked dauntingly large in scope
and I knew I would have to steer a
focused course after much thought I
decided to choose my themes my subjects
according to themes I thought were
important to history and culture at the
end of the 20th century first on my list
was the still unresolved memory of the
Second World War a subject of
longstanding interest to me I had close
knowledge of French social and political
tensions deriving from that era from the
writing of an earlier book called
unhealed wounds France and the close
Barbee affair the trip to Japan had
opened another Vista and when I thought
about it the prospect of studying
Holocaust memory in Germany seemed
particularly interesting I also decided
on the simplest approach possible I
would turn myself into a kind of
eighteenth-century traveller into
someone who explored the world through
physical experience as well as
conventional study in the hope and
expectation that I would eventually
carry my readers along with me on my
travels so in 1997 I set out to explore
the way the war is remembered today in
both Germany and in France
I was surprised by the rawness of
feeling in Germany after more than 50
years and I don't think anything could
have prepared me for my encounters with
the children of major Nazi perpetrators
who have lived their lives trying to
survive the shame I talked to Martin
Bormann jr. a man who has gone through
life with a notorious name he was 15
years old and in a special school near
Munich for the children of the Nazi
elite as the war came to an end he and
his schoolmates were told to run for
their lives Forman jr. was taken in by a
farmer he did not reveal his true name
as he had been told not to do one
evening alone in the farmers kitchen he
read a newspaper account of the in
absentia trial of his father and
Nuremberg he told me that he knew
immediately that what was written was
true and that he was completely
devastated Martin Bormann jr. was the
only child of Nazi perpetrators I met
who has been able to maintain love for
his parent and he did this by converting
to Roman Catholicism and becoming a
Catholic priest and spending the rest of
his life teaching children about what
happened in his country unlike the case
of Nicholas Frank the son of hands Frank
Hitler's Gauleiter in Poland who struck
me as a man who has contemplated suicide
more than once Nicholas who was a
political reporter for Sharon magazine
told me that not a day goes by that he
does not ask his father his executed
father why he did what he did his
rational answer is that Hans Frank was
an opportunist who would have done
whatever Hitler asked him to do for the
power it conferred his irrational fear
is that he the son may have similar
criminal tendencies many of the second
and third generation Germans I am
countered admitted that they feared
themselves in this way as it was
explained to me the concept of blood or
heredity is still strong in both the
German language and thought forms
sometimes the expression of remorse took
rather strange forms I happen by chance
to attend a klezmer concert of all
things in a little church in a village
near Stuttgart a Jewish man from New
Jersey and his partner were singing in
Yiddish to an audience of middle-aged
Germans to the children of the
perpetrator generation in other words
one rather sad song was about a mother
crooning to her small son be a good boy
and study hard and you'll grow up to be
a fine man I looked around me
to my surprise the audience was
sniffling and blinking back tears as I
left in the company of a woman from the
nearby Protestant Academy she said they
always have events like this and they
always cry nothing ever seems to help
the debate in Germany since the war has
not been about denial the Nuremberg
trials brought out the facts immediately
after the event Germans worry instead
about degrees of guilt and how long they
must remain accountable however of all
the countries I visited Germany has
tried to do the most in terms of
teaching its children the truth about
what happened and making amends Japan
has done the least in France the
situation has been quite different
because a falsified myth of heroism took
root right after the war in 1940 France
was occupied by the Germans in its
northern sector but the south of the
country was governed by a
collaborationist government under the
first world war hero mahadji Philippe da
among other acts of collaboration the
Vichy government offered to deliver
French Jews to the Nazis before being
asked to do so at the same time General
Charles de Gaulle was operating his
famous resistance movement out of London
and when the war ended and the Allies
won he was able to return to France and
triumph the goals political task was
plain in his view the French needed to
forget about Vichy as quickly as
possible in order to re-establish
Republican fronts once again this was
accomplished in several ways the first
was to claim that France the true France
had been in London with the goal while
the France that remained on the
continent was as the French say
illegitimate the second technique was to
firmly plant the myth that a nationwide
resistance to the Nazis had taken place
which was vastly untrue finally there
were purges of the most visible
collaborators including summary trials
and executions followed by blanket
amnesties so that no one else could ever
be brought to trial you may well wonder
how a story of almost universal
resistance could take root and last so
long since everyone alive during the war
knew the truth was otherwise the answer
is simple enough in human psychological
terms once the purges were complete
hundreds of thousands of people were
only too happy to comply they hope their
own deeds large or small would never see
the light of day and for decades they
did not I began this talk by telling you
that the deportations of the Jews of
France had remained unacknowledged in
the collective memory of the nation but
eventually this hidden history broke
through this is not as unusual as it may
sound
for one of the things I learned and my
travels around the world is that no
matter how carefully national leaders
try to hide a shameful story it will
eventually emerge and the principal
reason is I believe family the stories
of those who have been victimized or
ignored will eventually be known because
the people in question care so much they
do not forget what happened and they
pass it on to their children and their
grandchildren they may be silenced or
cowed in the beginning but as the
primary players die people whose history
has been suppressed or ignored may be
successful in bringing their story to
public attention no matter how many
years have passed what happened in the
North American Chinese diaspora for
example was explained to me by dr.
Joseph Wong a Chinese Canadian human
rights advocate it is in fact the story
of some of the people in this room
tonight let me read a few paragraphs
from long shadows
this is from the middle of my chapter
where I'm discussing the issue of what
happened in Japan and the recovery of
memory among Chinese the the descendants
of the Nanking Massacre as for the large
Chinese diaspora outside the mainland
almost 60 years passed before they were
able to confront the memory of Nanking
sometimes people didn't even discuss it
with each other said Joseph Wong a
Canadian physician and community
activist whose downtown Toronto office
is filled with plaques and mementos
honoring his work in support of Human
Rights the recent history of the Chinese
has made them diffident he said they
were under foreign occupation and even
their own governments had not have not
acted in their interests so people left
as refugees but often with the thought
that they would eventually return in
North America it took a long time for
the Chinese to put down roots and feel
confident enough to put their problem to
bring their problems of human rights to
public attention the Chinese diaspora
communities began to rally at the time
of the chandaman square massacre in 1989
in doing so they forged a cadre of more
confident leaders the first act of the
new San francisco-based
Global Alliance for preserving the
history of World War two in Asia was
quote a declaration to the Japanese
people and the Japanese government in
which they pointed out that as recently
as 1994 a minister of the government of
Japan had stated that the Nanking
Massacre was a Chinese fabrication they
urged Japanese quote people of
conscience to press their leaders to
apologize pay reparations and open their
archives to assist historians in their
research into quote Japanese misdeeds
not surprisingly the Government of Japan
did not respond but that was not the
expected outcome of the exercise
the point was lobbying and pressure
Global Alliance was joined by Japanese
both inside and outside Japan of whom
the most illustrious was the winner of
the Nobel Prize for Literature Kenzaburo
OE who wrote an article in the new york
times magazine titled denying history
disables japan in december 1997 exactly
sixty years after the event the first
full-length english-language expose of
the Nanking Massacre was published it
was authored by iris Chang a
chinese-american who had spent her
childhood listening to family stories
around the dinner table as she grew
older and tried to research the event
she was surprised to find nothing in the
libraries and it was not until 1994 at a
conference sponsored by the Global
Alliance in Cupertino California that
she finally believed that the quote folk
myth of her family as she put it was
accurate there were photographs of the
massacre on display in the hall that
nothing could have prepared her for
Chang's book The Rape of Nanking was
well received by historians including
many in Japan but not by the Japanese
government
but the subversive new medium of the
internet was about to play a prominent
role in the struggle over the right to
know the past the Global Alliance for
preserving the history of world war ii
in asia created a website with links to
additional information about the Nan's
van King Massacre and chat rooms in
which Japanese and Americans could
conduct open conversation but no one in
Japan linked activism with the new world
of technology more directly than
Yoshiyuki Misaki a college professor of
English in Fukuoka Kyushu Kyushu Misaki
used his website in Japanese and English
to call on the Government of Japan to
acknowledge history he posted details
about the Nanking Massacre that included
Western media news reports and the
confessions
of two men he informed his quote
visitors about the legal plight of Shiro
Asuma and called for world help
he described the Memorial Hall of the
victims of the Nanking Massacre located
in Nanking and the activities of the
Global Alliance for preserving the
history of World War two in Asia
I met Yoshi Yugi Yoshiyuki Misaki by
emailing him at his website and he told
me that in just two years 30,000 people
had visited his pages that meant
Japanese internet users had access to up
to the up-to-date international research
even if their school texts ignored or
glossed over the subject and their
politicians denied the facts outright
it is clear to me that the de Pepe
democracy of global information is
influencing history and memory in new
ways knowledge including historical
knowledge can no longer be sealed off in
quite the same way by political leaders
whose strategy it is to shape public
opinion through censorship similarly it
was 1995 before the new president of the
French Republic officially announced
that France was responsible for what
have happened to its Jews Vichy France
was not illegitimate after all in
longshadow's I take the reader with me
to the trial of Maurice peple in
Bordeaux in 1997 Apple had been an
ordinary civil servant in the service of
the French state during the war it was
his job to round up and deport the Jews
during this revealing and often
bizarrely funny trial the ambiguities of
fifty years of French myth-making were
exposed and the survivors and their
children finally had their day in court
as the second theme to long shadows I
came to think that there were few
subjects more compelling or important to
our understanding than the global fault
line of race the 20th century saw the
rise and fall of colonialism and races
were endemic throughout as populations
migrated from country to country in
unheard-of ways in the United States the
apparently in erasable legacy of chattel
slavery held many unanswered questions
for me questions I had wondered about
ever since the civil rights movement of
the 1960s I was particularly curious
about what Americans who were currently
lobbying for a formal apology and
reparations for slavery from their
government hoped to accomplish as an
obvious comparison I was intrigued by
the way South Africa was attempting to
bridge its transition from a racist
apartheid state to an inclusive
democracy through something called a
true
and Reconciliation Commission and how
this too might be poised to shape
national memory my trapped Iran the
United States which I've called the
shadow of slavery focuses on the failed
1997 initiative of Tony P Hall a
Democratic congressman from Ohio to
Shepherd a resolution through Congress
that would have seen the American
government apologized to African
Americans for the harm their ancestors
suffered as slaves under the
Constitution and laws of the United
States and on President Clinton's
president's initiative on race also
initiated in 1970 1997 t 1997 which also
must be seen as a failure I traveled
through the u.s. South talking to black
Americans who care the most about this
issue although the legacy of racism
naturally affects all and to whites such
as William winter the former government
governor of Mississippi who was a member
of the President's Commission on race
winter is a son of the plantation but he
has made important modernizing changes
to his state particularly in the field
of compulsory public education today
there's a new push for acknowledgement
in the form of reparations whether or
not this succeeds any better than Mr
Hall's initiative or that of President
Clinton has yet to be seen but changes
are afoot old cases of lynchings are
being reopened and retried across the
country and some form of memorializing
for the abuse of chattel slavery may yet
occur the subjects I've been discussing
all led in a natural way to questions
about collective identity which was the
third major theme I fastened on here I
chose to explore the way the Holocaust
has been incorporated into Jewish
identity over recent decades and also
the ways in which memorializing the
Holocaust has increasingly influenced
liberal thinking in the West an ongoing
process
began as the so called Nuremberg
principles of accountability for crimes
against humanity
and most recently played a role in the
decision of the NATO powers to intervene
in Kosovo in 1999 on the other side of
this collective memory divide I wanted
to examine how history came to be
distorted and manipulated by the opinion
makers of slobodan milosevic is serbia
with appalling consequences for millions
of people finally and most importantly
in my own mind my last theme was and is
justice and the role trials can play in
pacifying the unquiet past I asked
myself about the legacy of the Nuremberg
Tribunal where the top Nazis were judged
immediately after the war and then more
generally about the usefulness of war
crimes tribunals in reconciling
historical memory after times of crisis
when traditional values may have been
turned upside down by propaganda lies
and the chaos of war Nuremberg has been
on my mind since I was a child I
distinctly remember the day I saw the
Universal Declaration of Human Rights
posted on the walls of my junior school
and the thrill I felt when I pieced out
the big words with their even bigger
meanings I knew almost nothing about the
war needless to say but I divined the
importance of that document it seems to
me that there is a meaningful way to
handle the explosive past one that
requires national courage stresses facts
and insists upon accountability the
government-sponsored trial of Marty's
people as an accomplice to crimes
against humanity was a prime example of
this sort of courage another was South
Africa's Truth and Reconciliation
Commission in my own opinion one of the
most vivid
arts of longshadow's is my trip to the
small town of loosey-goosey key in the
trance Kai a backwards poverty-stricken
region of the country white people are
warned not to visit and where I was the
only white person in attendance at a
remarkable session of the TRC I watched
and listened as mothers spoke about sons
who had been murdered and as the
audience wept but at the same time I
slowly realized that I was witnessing
the emergence of the new national myth
of South Africa being shaped by the
commissioners of the TRC themselves the
old exclusive story of the Afrikaners
and their heroic God inspired victories
over the Zulu enemy was being replaced
before my eyes by the new exclusive
story of the ANC and the struggle for
liberation although I believe that will
likely take a generation before the
results of the Truth and Reconciliation
Commission are fully known the attempt
to make the structures of the former
apartheid state visible and transparent
and to help both perpetrators and
victims face the facts about the past
during the course of the transition to
democracy was original and notable the
TRC was a quasi legal quasi religious
forum based on confession and possible
amnesty but the same century that
witnessed genocide and world wars also
created formal judicial institutions of
great usefulness when it established in
universe in international law the
principle of individual response for
crimes against humanity even when orders
have been issued to carry out such acts
the tribunal at Nuremberg marked a high
point of the 20th century the principles
of accountability laid out at the
Nuremberg trials lay dormant during the
entirety of the Cold War
in 1993 in the face of crimes against
whole peoples in the Balkans and in
Rwanda the United Nations recreated
Nuremberg so to speak with another
internet International Criminal Tribunal
for both these places what this means is
that at the end of the 20th century the
commitment to accountability was revived
at the international level and when the
proposed permanent International
Criminal Court begins its operations in
a few years which it is certain to do in
spite of present objections primarily
from the United States the expectation
on the part of future tyrants that they
can remain immune to judgment will be
diminished not ended naturally but
diminished the indictment of General
Augusto Pinochet of Chile by a young
Spanish judge came directly from the
precedents established in international
law Nuremberg and more recently at the
ICTY in The Hague and just days ago in
an extraordinary development as you have
likely heard the legal way was cleared
in Belgrade for transferring slobodan
milosevic
to the Hague there are in other words
reasons for guarded optimism because if
I can sum up my years of research and
extraordinary encounters in a phrase the
road to reconciling the past must start
with ensuring that the powerful are
accountable for their actions and that
the victims are at the very least
acknowledged and I'd like to conclude if
I may by reading the last paragraphs of
long shadows
at the end of this journey it seems to
me that reconciling the long shadows
cast by the uneasy past may ultimately
depend on elements so basic that they
bring to mind a simple Slav proverb I
once came across and never forgot eat
bread and salt and speak the truth
they are the recovery of fact public
accountability and the instituting of
fair trials of one sort or another to
help mark ends and beginnings and to
return the moral compass as close to the
center as possible
the demand for politically expedient
solutions will always be present for the
sake of social harmony and perceived
stability responsible citizens are often
expected to put away the past and never
to speak publicly about what happened or
who was responsible but seeing through a
long lens peacemaking founded on
forgetting appears to have a limited
lifespan there are other ways in the
deep place where memory lives simple
actions can speak of a national
commitment to turn the historical page
official acknowledgments apologies if
necessary memorials to the victims
restitution permanent museums that tell
a factual story the teaching of
schoolchildren about the origins of
hatred all potent symbolic act but even
then the Germans call it vergangenheit
Spiegel T gung mastering or overcoming
the past a lofty ideal that is doomed to
failure not just because of the
immensity of the Nazi crimes for the
past it seems can never be overcome it
lurks forever in memory it loiterers in
cemeteries it shelters behind
beautifully painted movable screens as
in Japan
the past can only be managed with
remembrance with accountability with
justice
however frail however inadequate however
imperfect thank you very much yes and
before I do I'd like to point out that
iris Chang is in the audience the author
of The Rape of Nanking and iris has done
a tremendous amount to bring the story
of what happened in China to public
attention questions yes just a minute
there's okay there's a microphone here
mm-hmm
in the beginning of your talk you spoke
about the Germans hue you said second
and third-generation Germans I almost
had a fear of themselves a little bit
and what from the past can you elaborate
a little bit yes I can
in fact I'm hesitant because if you
don't mind there's a paragraph in my
book where I meet with us with a
therapist in Berlin who talks to me
about Chris Eisley this fear that
Germans have of having this what they
consider to be criminal blood I wonder
would I have time to read a couple of
paragraphs okay I will in fact I think I
know where it is I had actually thought
of reading this but then thought maybe I
wouldn't have time because it's
extremely interesting and this comes at
the end of my chapter on Germany I'm
back in Berlin at the end of my journey
when an acquaintance tells me that a
therapist named Hanny Lou rest's and her
partner's partner runs psychotherapy
workshops for young Germans as well as
for the children of Jewish survivors and
then we meet in a small cafe and we are
having a conversation we are not
interested in cheap reconciliation we're
interested in honest confrontation and
getting to know one another she says in
Psychological terms the mass murder of
Jews has not yet been integrated in this
country most Germans have never met a
Jew and there is a tremendous amount of
projection on both sides she tells me
that young Germans are ashamed they
fantasize that the Jews in the group
will see them as Nazis while the Jews
are afraid that they of being used as
all-forgiving salon Jews by the Germans
the Jews also feel shame she says the
shame of being the child of a victim
abuse produces shame her groups are
composed of about 16 people 75% of them
the children of perpetrators
we ask everyone why they have come the
Germans often do not express their
motives as clearly they say they are
students of this or that but they do not
say with it what always comes out sooner
or later that what they really want to
know is how their grandfather influenced
their father and how their father has
influenced them deep down they fear they
may have criminal tendencies we still
have this blood thing in Germany we
called abdomen meaning from which stem
you come so people come here with a
conscious or subconscious subconscious
idea of genetic culpability it's pure
fantasy but it can be powerful and
disabling what happens when it becomes
clear that simple reconciliation is not
really possible I asked her it is a hard
liberating moment for everyone a wake-up
we cannot change reality but we try not
to flatten it either we can only help
each other to deal with it and recognize
each other's innocence we are neither
perpetrators or victims we are the
children and the grandchildren we try to
rid ourselves of the projections and the
fantasies about genetic guilt and have
compassion for our set for ourselves
after all the hardness we have inherited
because accepting ourselves after what
our families did is the most difficult
thing of all to my surprise honey is
crime it's very touching to see people
learn to confront themselves in their
conflicts with such courage she whispers
I reach across the table and take her
hand she is German not Jewish I
understand with a slight shock that in
helping others she is trying to heal
herself I hope that answers your
question
yes this is not on on the subject that
your book is on but I wonder because I
know there several people here who are
writers or would-be writers could you
say a few words about your process of
writing how you collect the material
what you do with that how you record it
and so on well I can tell you what I did
for this book um I I traveled to all the
places of the book obviously before I
went I would spend many months studying
and I made appointments with people who
I thought were important to talk to some
but I deliberately left a few I
deliberately left a great deal loose so
that when I got there people could
direct me or I could just follow my nose
and then I simply went and traveled and
met people and talked essentially has
experiences so that this is a very
special kind of travel book the the
reader comes with me and has the
experiences and thinks with me and and
and so on so to answer your question I
did it in two stages
one the library research which is the
usual conventional form and the other
actually getting out there and and
traveling
yes well there are a number of
comparisons being done by various
scholars and researchers between the
adequacy of determine redress and
continuously Nile by the Japanese but it
wasn't much discussed on your recent
time actually the biggest must qualify
the lawyers and distortion astrium the
u.s. deparment state they've been doing
cover-ups since 1946 until today right
before the u.s. got kicked out the Human
Rights Commission in March the US
Department of State
filed a statement of interest with the
court saying forcing women 200 thousands
of going into a sexual slavery was a
work on committed by the Japanese
government but that's protected by the
national sovereignty so it cannot be
sued and then turns out the u.s. two US
government knew the fact the word come
from woman since 1946 and never be
disclosed until the Japanese got me
actually released a referee in 1992 oh I
have must confess I didn't really look
so I don't know whether you address the
u.s. role in this whole conspiracy no I
have no I just the u.s. role but I just
like to say briefly about sovereignty
that as you cert as you probably know
the old notion of absolute sovereignty
is breaking down slightly the
international courts for instance in in
The Hague and in and for Rwanda
operating in Tanzania are trying people
outside the boundaries of their
countries and if slobodan milosevic is
in fact transferred to the hague he will
become the first leader of a country
ever to stand trial in this way
accord in the international forum
outside his country so there's a long
way to go before the ideal of
sovereignty which remains a very
important one is flexible enough I think
to overcome or to deal with these
emerging cases but I think that I think
it is happening I think we are going to
see it in the same way as we are going
to see an International Criminal Court
yes there's a question over there if you
have chance to interview a u.s. POWs who
have been suffer horribly during World
War two who have enslaved by Japanese
company have you have chance to
interview those people no those are the
people actually in this country and been
neglected for almost 60 years
so no sovereignty issue but these are I
think that's a reality and facing to the
truth issue and I met some of these
people at a conference in in Toronto
actually and held by the Global Alliance
but since my research on Japan was done
in Japan I did not interview American
POWs who were imprisoned in Japan
I'm hearing some things like the most
vintage potentially ending up in the
world in Ag and MP oh [ __ ] charged at
perhaps Arielle sharone in charge the
d'el djem for the abroad Sabra Massacre
do you think that these things are are
bringing about a new kind of
accountability or is it alternative
alternatively a new way that societies
are assigned to blame or has this sort
of thing always happened in some way no
way hasn't always happened has any brief
look at history will tell us I think
that there that there's something new in
the air is it's quite new it began at
Nuremberg and then went into deep freeze
over the Cold War but what happened at
the end of the Cold War when we began to
see these awful civil wars evolve in the
world and in particular what was
happening in the Balkans there was
tremendous pressure on the United
Nations and the Security Council to do
something anything because we were all
watching what was happening on
television I mean this is a new element
that we watch Wars live on television
surrounded by ads for mutual funds and
there's something grotesque about this I
think we all might agree and it was only
after the bombing of the marketplace in
Sarajevo which was broadcast that there
was move to intervene in that war but
the point I'm making is that there was
tremendous pressure on the Security
Council to make a move and what they did
was create these courts and in doing so
they have revived to the principles of
Nuremberg and it's like they've opened
something Pandora's box but good stuff
we just have to see if the rules ever
get applied to the winners
that's a very good point of course I
think that in fact in longshadow's I
talked about the fact that ever since
Nuremberg has remained controversial and
one of the things that's controversial
but Nuremberg is that people say it was
Victor's justice of course it was
Victor's justice but I think that we can
acknowledge that and say there was still
just as done they're not complete
justice I think it's a mistake to think
we are going to get complete justice or
complete anything in our attempts there
was some justice yes you know on
cultural myth affecting historical
perspective did you find that you
yourself had been sort of shaped by some
of the ideals of the cultures you
identify with
well I'm Canadian and we well we don't
have wars but we have plenty of myths
and we've we have grown up with them in
the same way that people in every
country have grown up with the myths of
their country I would make a distinction
between the kind of mythologies that all
nations create for themselves which are
a part of the way we understand who we
are living in a geographical space and
that line that is passed over when the
mythology's become dangerous when they
become ethnic in character and exclusive
and promote unfortunate events so I
don't think we want to or even ever
could avoid the kind of general myth
making that we all do but we do have to
keep an eye on it because it isn't
always composed of truth yes
investigation in the South especially in
the United States about slavery did you
find I wasn't clear from your comments
that there is some denial of the
widespread of the existence of it or
just the responsibility to and three
generations after the fact what was the
mythology that you were trying to
describe regarding our concepts
regarding slavery well for the most part
nobody was denying that there there had
been chattel slavery nobody would do
that in this country
although I did interview one individual
who still lives on his plantation who
informed me that um that African
Americans that the slaves actually were
very well-off because they had excellent
Medicare and he I've actually written
about him in some detail a man like this
could be dismissed as a as a as just you
know some kind of kook I suppose but he
was also spouting ideology that that
suggested he might be part of a of a
far-right movement and so I was quite I
was became more interested in him in
general what I've found in interviewing
black African Americans in the South was
mmm that there was a tremendous yearning
for some kind of official
acknowledgement of the fact of slavery
some apology in this country a monument
there is nothing on the Washington Mall
for instance which is the heartland of
of historical memory some kind something
official now I know a lot of Americans
counter that and say well this is a long
time ago there's nobody alive today who
either was involved as a slaver or as an
enslaved person who would apologize to
whom I think the answer to that is a
simple one and it is that when a nation
has approved of or condoned abuse in one
way or another the apology must come
from the nation on behalf of the nation
and it doesn't matter whether the people
are still alive their descendants are
alive the same with people who've come
as immigrants they may say well I wasn't
here my families were somewhere else
being abused by other people this has
nothing to do with me it's the same
thing when we when we come to a country
as an immigrant it seems to me that we
adopt that nationality and we adopt the
history too so that the government then
apologizes on behalf of all living
people for what was conducted in its
name and as I say I found a tremendous
yearning for some kind of act whether it
involve restitution ie money or not
yes
tires Chang firstly I just want to thank
you so much for having written this
brilliant book I think this goes a long
way and have helping us understand how
nations can lie to each other and how
people can actually contribute to this
lack of understanding of history by
remain passive I mean in the course of
my own research and writing about The
Rape of Nanking I was pretty shocked to
learn how the US government itself was
determined to sweep a lot of the World
War two history under the rug and one of
the most shocking revelations was that
the US government forced the National
Archives to return the documents seized
by American occupation forces in Japan
back to Japan which from which point we
have never seen the document since and
as another member of the audience had
pointed out the US government has also
suppressed some of the stories of the
sex slaves of the Japanese Imperial Army
these Korean comfort women and the
stories of torture committed by Japanese
doctors in laboratories like unit 731
but I would say that there have been
encouraging signs in this country since
the publication of The Rape of Nanking
and other books the Japanese Imperial
Army Disclosure Act has been signed into
law now by President Clinton and oh so
there is a bill at the Honda Rohrabacher
bill which is now helping on the u.s.
POWs push for restitution from Japanese
companies that exploited them and
tortured them during World War two so
there are encouraging signs but I still
think we still have a lot more I think
work to do in terms of political
activism and education because I still
believe there exists a double standard
between the US perception of
the Japanese Imperial Japanese Imperial
war crimes that no so some of the [ __ ]
German atrocities for example the
Japanese Imperial
Disclosure Act is not quite the same as
the Nazi Imperial Disclosure Act excuse
me the Nazi Disclosure Act in that the
u.s. government still has the right to
keep some documents classified if
they're considered capable of
jeopardizing national security so I
think this is not really a question it's
just my cut appeal to everybody to
actually continue to push the United
States government for full disclosure of
these historical documents thank you
thank you to hide this US government
well there are a lot of I think
revelations that would embarrass the
United States government such as the
fact that the United States actually
exonerated the Japanese doctors that
committed medical atrocities such as
live dissections in China in exchange
for their medical data which the United
States government was rumored to have
used for their own purposes during the
Korean War so we don't really we won't
know the truth about this until the
records are released
however these records are actually in
the process of being systematically
destroyed as writers unearth them I mean
this has been enough of a concern to
make certain politicians like senator
Feinstein
protest against the thesis destruction
so it's just I think it's important for
us to know that keep you know even 50
years after the fact there are forces
that political forces that are trying to
suppress this history I'd also I'd like
to to add that it is lobby groups such
as the Global Alliance that have forced
change in other places in France for
example it was a lobby group of
civilians of the the children and
grandchildren of victims that forced
change in that country as well and as as
I mentioned there there have been trials
in France there's been a complete not a
complete turnaround there's still a
great deal of discussion about the truth
of post-war French history but
tremendous efforts are being made and it
came about as a result of lobbying
other people well many people know the
movie yeah
bridge over the river kwai won the Oscar
in 1956 but nobody really know which
Japanese company were behind the
enslavement and turned out to be
headquartered in Chicago Mitsubishi
there are as many as a 10 million people
enslaved and more than half then died 37
percent American POWs I Indians wavered
and today the US government is the one
blocking justice and the Japanese are
coming to San Francisco in September to
mark the fifth anniversary of the peace
treaty yet
the same time and refused to apologize
would you comment on your attitude well
all I can say is that I'm sure your
group will be there to meet them yes you
mentioned during the course year talk
the influence of the internet on many of
these events now and in the course of
answering one of the questions you also
mentioned television and the fact that
we see war live with the fact that
virtually anybody today you go out and
have a video camera do you think that
technology is going to play a big role
in perhaps giving us greater hope for
the future yes I have mixed feelings
about the role of Technology um you
mentioned the video camera in Freetown
Sierra Leone a man who happened to be on
the street when a killing was taking
place took a picture of what what took a
video of what was occurring that video
was broadcast on CNN on the CBC in
Canada and in South Africa by the South
Africa Broadcasting Corporation and was
quite instrumental in creating
international interest in getting in
there and trying to stop what was going
on there sending peacekeepers and etc on
the other hand the producer who first
looked at that video and said shall we
broadcast it said that she went through
and I quote her a long night of the soul
before deciding whether to broadcast it
how much horror how much should how much
should we see on television as we're
sitting there munching popcorn which
brings me to my second concern because
as we watch wars on television we become
unwittingly bystanders there's a lot of
interest today in the role of bystanders
during the Nazi era and in and in France
etc the bystanders are the people that
vast group in the middle that is not
appart they're not perpetrators and
they're not resistance fighters they're
kind of wondering which way the wind is
going to blow and they're ready to kind
of help out wherever it blows if it
looks like that's the positive direction
and maybe the vast majority of the human
race is like that we're not all
courageous nor are we all willing to
risk our lives the point I'm making is
that we become unwitting bystanders when
we watch these events on television and
what what this is going to do to us is I
think still unclear I think it's quite
possible that as I was suggesting before
the United Nations decided to go into
into Bosnia or NATO rather go into
Bosnia because so many people felt some
kind of guilt at having watched what
they watched and it being incapable of
doing anything about it so I think that
technology is going to play a very
important role in the way we respond to
future Wars yes were you tempted to look
at the Soviet Union's repression of
historical fact that seems to be the
most prominent almost in the century
yes I certainly could have and I and I
was tempted it was so huge that I felt
that in the context of one book I
couldn't include the Soviet Union I
would like to say that the the countries
that I've chosen and the subjects that
I've chosen to explore represent what I
have found to be archetypal ways that
nations deal with the past either by
denial either by fabricating some kind
of myth by trying to deal with it
through trials or whatever and can be
extrapolated to a number of other
countries I also chose places because of
the immensity of this project where I
had at least some beginnings of
knowledge about the subject in question
before I began but yes somebody should
write that book
yes iris what in your opinion was most
shocking revelation become out of here
three years of research was there
anything that may have surprised you
more than anything else as you set out
undertake this journey
I think what surprised me it wasn't
talking in a negative sense it was
surprising in a very positive sense was
how fiercely ordinary people will fight
to have their story told no matter how
it has been suppressed or for how many
years the TRC hearing that I attended in
loosey-goosey key concerned something
that had happened in 1961 between two
groups of black South Africans and they
had never been allowed to talk about it
before and they were officially talking
about it to the commissioners of the TRC
and it was for them an extraordinary
occasion the occasion of their lives
I found this everywhere that ordinary
people will fight very very hard and
then eventually their stories are told
and are known and I think this is
tremendous encouraging
yes with the prevalence of the internet
how you know how can countries like say
Japan or China expect to you know keep
information outside of you know from
textbooks and as such I mean what's
what's their their thinking behind that
well the thinking is very it is
pre-internet thinking it's old-fashioned
I mean that was a very successful
technique in the past you just censored
a textbook on the point I made by using
the example of Yoshi Yoshi Yuki Misaki
in Japan is that it just doesn't work
anymore if people can just sit in front
of a television screen and click into a
website and then find and find all the
information
who cares where their textbooks are
being censored I mean it's important of
course because teachers must teach but
it will be there what they're still
doing that as an ongoing basis not not
something that was done in the past but
it's still being done at the present
well yes I mean you know governments
don't give up on what's been successful
in the past
they'll keep trying yes I've heard
communist China they blocked the
Internet I guess maybe you might know
that but I really walked things over
there I don't know about Japan yes but
then people find a way around it that's
the nature of the beast isn't it
something's blocked then somebody else
finds a way to unblock it and I think
that in the long term it's going to be
there and it's going to be harder it
won't be impossible maybe it will be
impossible for them to block it entirely
but it's going to be a little game for a
little little while
yes nothing I can talk about yet
man note will allow you some time to
speak with people individually while you
sign books for those of you who are
aware c-span M has done filming that
only got the backs of your heads
thank you that they played in Q&A they
will be doing some filming while she's
signing books at brainy areas we prefer
not to be included in that footage just
let me know and we'll change the
sequence to members whatever but we're
very pleased to have a message searches
such as we're Paris's broadcast on
c-span we'll talk to be the person on
the next few weeks
lately